he's going Gary it's going well am I on
yeah everyone thank you so thank you
very much for for for accepting our
invitation here um yeah so so we usually
like to start off on a personal note for
all of our speakers and so you know
let's let's sort of go through like
where were you born where were you
raised sure and then maybe talk about
like what was your first taste of
entrepreneurship sure about that so I
was born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union I came to the u.s. in 1978 when I
was 3 I spent one year in Queens New
York big ups to Queens ok and then I
moved to New Jersey and basically grew
up in Edison New Jersey and my first
taste of entrepreneurship was when I was
4 and when I was 5 when we moved to New
Jersey I started very interested in
business a lot of I see a lot of
familiar faces so I think a lot of
people might know the lemonade stand
story but the ones that know me a little
bit deeper and I know the VA one which
is the first thing I really did was
literally a week into living in this
townhouse development dogwood meadows in
Edison New Jersey I walked around the
neighborhood on one day pulled the
flowers out of people's yards and
Wrangler or about and sold the flowers
back to that so much we're proud of that
but that's the first taste you know
which if you think about it was a pretty
smart business model I didn't really sit
on a lot of inventory good so that was
my first taste and then I got really
serious about lemonade stands when I was
sixth soprano style right yeah six
lemonade stands I literally convinced
all my friends in the neighborhood to
man and woman the lemonade stands all
day and and I spent all my time
ironically making signs and trying to
figure out which trees and you know I
was yeah I mean I still think that might
be one of my brother
I mean we literally ran lemonade stands
out of those 90 days of that summer
between first grade and kindergarten I
mean like like 50 of the 90 days I had
my friends standing behind a stand for
like seven hours so good sales child
labor
yeah and the other thing too like I
wanted to talk about was fast for a
little bit talk about how you had 30
grand
under your bed mm-hmm at 14 years years
old yeah and how you you did not sell we
you promised you did that people say you
did so we're from Jersey right so uh
when I was 12 I don't know you know
looking around the private some guys in
this age group baseball cards completely
took over okay America look like the 87
tops and you know 87 89 90 91 92 so I
was in that age group and I started
doing baseball card shows in the malls
of New Jersey and you know that was what
I really learned how to become I would
tell you that I'm just pretty sure that
the foundation of my business success
was selling baseball cards when I was 11
12 13 14 because when you sold cards at
a mall or a convention center or a
firehouse or whatever the places I did
these shows you would stand behind a
table for 11 hours and all you really
did was read people right like I'm
basically step on a table and I
basically just read people on how they
were looking at my cases and I would
move things you know I basically still
just read people my life is reading
people and trying to understand consumer
behavior and then reverse engineer how
to get your money and you know and I
think that um that's what happened you
know I I was making two to three four
thousand dollars a weekend some baseball
cards when I was 12 and you know that
was a great thing for me because I was
failing all my classes at that point and
you know it was a nice self-esteem boost
to like you know when my teacher would
call me up and say I'm so disappointed
in you you know you have so much
potential but you've got like a 36
French others class it was easy you know
that felt bad and you know I'm a good
guy wasn't mad a teacher I was mad I was
I felt bad but it was easy for me like
to go back to my desk and be like
yeah but I mean 3,300 bucks this weekend
and prorated you know I make $160,000 a
year and so and I only work one or two
days you know and so yes yes okay so
talk about that where you had failed all
your classes and you had mentioned that
your mom's friend had tried to make you
feel bad because like her son was going
down no no my friend's mom oh friend's
mom okay she was okay no it was just a
story in my life when I was 15 16 17 all
my friends started getting accepted to
all these good schools whatever 17 16
and there's just one story that I was
always stuck in my craw one of my best
friend's mom was proud of him you know I
was gonna grade school I get it she
wasn't I think she was really sure she's
a super nice lady she wasn't trying to
get me but she definitely got this day
was extra feeling proud and kind of just
she knew I was a [ __ ] student and she's
like so Garrity I don't if you heard
Adams going to you know panel
yeah and I was like yeah yeah and I just
remembered the way she delivered him and
I I just remember we were standing in
his driveway playing basketball and the
way she delivered it was to get me and I
just remember sitting there saying lady
you have no [ __ ] idea your son's
gonna work for me one day I'm gonna ask
you about that is he working for you
nobody's good okay so let's let's go
fast-forward to 1997 well you took took
your dad's business you grew it from you
know two million to sixty million
degrees oh I'm sorry
and you grew that to 60 million in seven
years yeah talk about that like you know
you had you had created this Wine
Library TV and that sort of puts you on
so six okay much more a lot of times
people think why never eaten even really
drove it but really what's wrong
ironically what drove it is much more
what I actually talk about me look the
only thing I care about is marketing and
doing business in the year that we
actually live in that is my true pet
peeves slash POV in the world it's 2014
if everything that you're trying to tell
people in the world right now is not
mobile first you're an idiot right look
because the eyes and ears in 2014 are
consuming more and more on mobile like
it's just the habits
the current state of the way people buy
and think and our story told to in 1997
I said to myself you know listen this is
1997 I was 22 years old at this point
I've only owned my own computer for a
year and a half I mean I basically have
never used a computer until I was like
19 20 years old it's just I grew up in a
different time like you know computer
class was something we took you've heard
what kind of student I was I don't know
what the [ __ ] I was doing a computer
class I still can't tell you right and
so you know what happened was it was
1997 I launched winelibrary.com I paid
some guy $15,000 he ripped me off he
made an HTML site that probably took him
two minutes he claimed it took four
weeks I've learned since then right and
and I've watched winelibrary.com and I
built winelibrary.com on the back of
having an e-commerce site when nobody
else did and way more importantly it was
more about 1998-99 when I started the
email service when nobody was doing that
I mean email marketing is still being
innovated as we know right now nobody
was doing it I built up huge lists at
the time 50,000 customers getting open
rates that were in 80% because nobody
was nobody was email marketing so it
wasn't spammed out yet right so people
were I mean for all of you that remember
98 99 look you read every email every
word right cuz we just got to have we
done with email back in a day in the day
and so um yeah I mean I built it on
email marketing and then Google AdWords
came out nobody was thinking about that
in the liquor business I'm just I'm the
word wine for five cents before they
bumped it to a 10 cent minimum I mean I
owned wine first result for 10 cents of
Google AdWords for nine and a half
months before somebody bid me up just it
was just a different world
like it wasn't people were worried about
buying ads in the Wine Spectator and
Direct Mail on their traditional
marketing is still something people very
much believed in you could imagine how
it was viewed in 99 people trying to
talk about what's the ROI of social
media or things of that nature I mean
people weren't even thinking about
banner retargeting and [ __ ] like that
yes some so I did actually went in your
old videos The Wine Library TV videos
and you have this one video where you're
like tasting wine on snow does that we
have ether Jets per gallon so it was
like you Julie came out yeah and my lead
developer came up to me
YouTube was like maybe six weeks old and
he came up to me is okay listen remember
a year ago and you were asking me like
how much it would cost if we put wine
videos on their website so look a year
or two earlier I came to I was like I
don't make videos on the internet I was
like and then you know he ran the
bandwidth cost and it was like cool if
like nine people watch it it's eight
billion dollars right forget it
and so he's like remember that you
should check this thing out and I looked
at YouTube
it just felt super like holy crap felt
very much like e-commerce I was like
this is gonna be huge
in early 2006 I started Wine Library TV
for 19 months I did that share 5 days a
week and nobody gave a [ __ ] right so I
get emails which I get 50 of them a day
for entrepreneurs of like hey look I
know you always talk about patience like
I've been doing this it's not working
traction should I give up and do
something else inevitably I'll email
back and be like how long have you been
doing it oh four months and I'm like
[ __ ] you like you want this to be your
life and you're giving up after four
months are you out of your mind so I did
it from 19 months nobody cared
and during that 19 months you know I was
starting to understand what was you know
really blend was going on and like the
Pepsi and mentos and all that stuff and
I was like what can I do it was a huge
snowstorm like yesterday in Jersey and I
just went outside and taped my episode
during the snow sure enough from page
dig and all those things you know I was
trying to have growth hack yeah you know
or whatever I was trying to understand
what would make it reach people outside
of this very narrow nature you know
hardcore whiners
how many how many followers did you have
on the show earlier I don't know one
thing I made a huge mistake about four
months into the show my shirt was 20
minutes long and there was a video
player called viddler that let you tag
certain spots that YouTube didn't and I
took myself off of YouTube and started
using viddler because I could tag the
four wines I did on each episode and if
you wanted to watch the third wine you
could just hit the button watch the
review of the third wine somewhat I
didn't really I mean that's probably the
most critical mistake I've made from a
brand building which is not investing in
YouTube all those years I've built up a
huge following I kind of let it go and
look that's the ironic thing right like
I know that I'm a poster child of people
that broke out on video and I did I mean
you can go look right now and you won't
be to me cuz I put him on we later have
a thousand or two thousand views on
YouTube I didn't do it on YouTube I did
it on the website itself right I mean I
you know based on the bandwidth causing
some of the stuff in filler was showing
at that point there was twenty five
thousand a day got up to about 150
thousand episode yeah nothing too crazy
by today's standards but an O six and a
seven and o eight people weren't
watching you you know online videos like
we do now and they were twenty five
minute videos but that sort of puts you
on the map and then you you roll crush
it and that really gave you Twitter
lists what really changed my career okay
Twitter came out again so YouTube came
out I was like yes and like I was right
about like e-commerce and I was right
about SEO and I was right about YouTube
and then I started learning about tech a
little bit I started meeting TechCrunch
and then I seen YouTube sells for
billion dollars and it writes about
angel investors and like how these
people make money and I was like [ __ ]
that seems like a really interesting way
to like I'm right about a lot of things
yes it's growing my business
but that I put in 50 thousand bucks and
me like 90 billion dollars I like that
so I promised myself that the next thing
that I saw that was like that I would
try to angel invest so it took more
about the age of SC so Twitter came
along and it's just last year Twitter
came along everybody thought it was
stupid I immediately was I completely
obsessed with it
I jumped all in and you know for a long
time there before Ashton came along and
real people went on it you know I was in
the top 30 follow people on Twitter I
spent 8 hours a day on it I answer
everybody's questions I just completely
went all-in I use summize comm that
later got bought by Twitter to search
people bring to use cabernet and then
look any people said the word cabernet
on Twitter that day and I literally
replied everyone which one how did you
like it when you go to Napa and not
trying to sell them on anything just
trying to establish you know was like a
cocktail party was like this except I'm
giving a presentation now when it's over
we can all talk and that's something I
love and so Twitter was really deep you
know that was very very big for me
because that's when you know Kevin Rose
indignation called out my show and all
of a sudden there's these 30 people that
were like much further ahead of
everybody else and followers and they
were all from a tech TV and like from
the world and I was like this wine guy
and everybody was fascinated by it and
then Conan's producers reached out and
that changed my career traditional media
you know Conan O'Brien's producers
emailed me look do you want to be on the
show and I was like yeah and sure enough
showed up and they took me the studio
and the first time I was ever on TV I
was just pushed out and did a skit with
Conan yeah yeah that's so fast 14 2009
yeah oh you're starting vaynermedia yes
with your brother AJ mm-hmm by the way
how's it like working with your brother
I have two brothers myself I mean is it
one day you're like fistfight and the
next day you're like all cool like that
no it's like yeah one day I want to kiss
him on the face and the next day I want
to kiss him on the face you know my
brother's my best friend and you know
it's 11 years younger than me and so you
know we have almost my dad's a
workaholic and not super ly emotionally
unbelievable he's a little bit of a
different introvert kind of style so my
brother you know my brother when I was
17 he was six right we have we have a
very kind of like fatherly brotherly
relationship you know were very very
close I've been training him an
entrepreneurship since he was like eight
I mean poor guy when he was like yes
it's on the money lemonade stands and no
because we lived in Huntington County
New Jersey they're like farm country
there was no cars driving bus but when
he was like 9 we started spending every
single Saturday waking up at 4 o'clock
in the morning to go to flea markets and
garage sale so that he would post
everything flip it on eBay yeah we're
very close I loved working with my dad
yeah I equally loved working with my
brother I hope I get a chance to work
with my children family businesses if
you over communicate and you care about
the other person more than you care
about yourself or the single so why did
you get out of the wine business
completely
you could have because nothing kills
entrepreneurship more than bad rules and
the liquor industry has rules yeah
the end can't ship everywhere politics
you don't think it's a disruptive
industry like you know the flip side I
know that one day we got a letter from
Texas and we couldn't ship it anymore
because that's retailers that we were
taking business from paying the
politicians and they changed the law
that making for thirty thousand dollars
in kickbacks under the table I lost four
point nine million dollars in sales in
one minute and after fighting it for 20
years of your life you get frustrated
and some of the liquor industry yourself
I do not want my upside or hard work or
all the effort that I put in controlled
by a couple of human beings and that's
what liquor laws prohibition came it's
state by state regulated there's a ton
of shady stuff it's completely it just
ultimately sucked the energy out of me
and it's the liquid industry's lost
because I would have been great
entrepreneur and done a lot of great
things for the industry and they deserve
to lose so gonna get into the liquor
business maybe think again what's the
most single most important advice your
dad gave you growing up so hands down
the best piece of advice my dad gave me
was back my dad is from the old country
I'm a storyteller I was one strike
policy if you if you embellish to my dad
one time and it's not true you're out
sunlight Soviet stones so you have a
Soviet dip it's a really sad living yes
it was really good for me because I was
the other way and it really started a
course correction for me that ultimately
put me to the finish line because of
social media in the transparent world
but it started with my dad and I'm so
grateful because you know for a lot of
you hear that either don't know me
because you're consuming me right now or
for ones that did and you think back to
the first time you were aware of me this
is there's a you know I am very car
salesman [ __ ] you know like there's
a 50% of the audience that doesn't like
me at first and if it wasn't for my dad
those people would have stayed not
liking me and the other
I would have converted whereas because
of my dad the 85% do you like me in the
energy I convert the other 15% because I
back up my sizzle with my steak and God
has a lot to do with the fact that I've
been honest and done the right things
and right hook okay so what is the book
what inspired you the books about
producing content on social networks I
believe that the most cost attractive
way to communicate to the end user in
today's world is by producing content
that is native to the platforms that
most people are spending their time on
and so I'm a humongous fan of producing
content for Instagram and Pinterest and
Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr and
buying as long as you know what you're
doing and who you're trying to reach and
understand the nuances Bailey who's been
doing this for four years I feel that
most people use social networks that's
distribution instead of we slowly tell
so I think most people write an article
or want to do something or have a
ecommerce site and then put a link on
Twitter or Facebook or Google+ or
what-have-you and just drive people
towards it don't believe that's the way
to do it I think the way to do it is to
respect the platform understand that
real pictures work on Instagram
infographics work on Pinterest which
hashtags work on twitter blah blah and
so I what dad got into a rabbit hole of
reading the negative reviews of crushing
Thank You economy my first two books on
Amazon and I got me really pissed and
like let's just I don't know like I
don't know why I was doing this why I
was pissing my stuff off but I was
reading every one-star review two star
review on Amazon just getting all worked
up and the basic theme was these are two
great books or like if they were really
the basic theme was this is fine but
these are why books why I wanted a house
you why did he show me I got oh he's
winning show me Gary
is one of the words and 100 case studies
of good and bad content I wanted to
write a how-to that's what I set out to
do with this book I feel that social
media reminds me right now where
ecommerce was right before the bubble
burst right be Commerce was happening in
99 2000 2001 Wall Street collapse all
the overvalued company's collapse and
everybody abandons like like there was
like Google bleep articles written in
2001 about the Internet they're pretty
funny like people having real solid
arguments that that the internet is dead
because the stock market crashed it was
ludicrous but that's what I feel like
about social right now is they're so
hyped and so talked about for the last
six or seven years and most people suck
at it because all we do is push on it
and I feel like there's an interesting
time now that I talk about it again I
think actually it's never been more
interesting for me to mark it on social
that right now because Facebook's doing
organic reach drops everybody's being
cynical but the upside has never been
greater the clients that I work with for
my missus I'm coming later than ever my
book is so dramatically more than my
last two because of the execution I've
done within social for it and so I just
thought was the right time to write this
book so because when I saw the title
book and you know the translation you
know most people are just asking for
your business on social or bragging
about themselves it's just very South
you know and I just feel like you have
to give first I mean I love the leverage
of giving in life I mean stuff my mother
Teresa I just I secretly believe it's
leverage like if you're willing to and
you can give first in whatever manner
including like this interview right like
I don't give and you give and you gain
leverage that's what I've executed in
social in 2012 on all my social channels
I asked for nothing they put out content
and responded to a billion people's
questions in 2013 second half I started
throwing right hooks because my book
I converted better views I build up
equity mean you're willing to do more
for your parents or your best friends
than you are for your acquaintances
you're willing to do more for your
acquaintance than your honor for a
stranger
that's just how society works so that's
why the recently just boxing metaphor is
I think so community as a science I mean
I know data things like what primary
colors I should use on the bottom of
left of a picture on Instagram to over
index on likes like there's a science
and I don't want time to post on
Facebook how many letters fusing a
facebook status update if I'm doing it
after 6:00 p.m. that will over index up
shareability it's a science to me where
most people don't think social science
is a very scientific thing and that's
why kickboxing is so cute they're so
similar the masses just think it's like
I'm eating cheese I'm walking my dog
here's a picture of my kid in Halloween
it's not bad for me so so I like that
you know give value to people first and
then you get so this get value people
defer up in your users value and then
guilt them to seven survivor if you give
a ton a ton a ton a ton you're in a
better position to ask right but I think
one thing are clarified because I think
some people have money here this thesis
of mine can get real cynical you know I
think the circle of you is like oh
you're just doing good things to get
something to return for me it's you give
and it gives you permission to ask for
me as a business startup you know you
know you know cuz sucks goes to Harvard
and builds Facebook now every single I
knew they'd get everyone thinks are an
entrepreneur where Amelie if you look my
point of view they're just kids that
figured out how to work the school
system right and so I'm looking through
a world right now where I'm seeing I've
never seen anything like we're looking
through now which is literally everybody
thinks they're an entrepreneur and
there's this entitlement that comes
along with it that has been stunning to
me I've always lived my life under the
notion of the customer's always right
I deserve
and I have to over-deliver in our
startup ecosystem in this room and this
vibe there's a stunning kind of
entitlement that I started a startup and
like I should have customers like like
it's insane to me and I think there's a
huge entitlement and so to me by giving
a lot it just gives you the ability to
ask doesn't mean you're yet and so I
think that's something people have to
learn I mean if you do not bring value
your product will not succeed and the
amount of products that are being built
right now that do not provide any value
their features their features this this
is a good segue to now we're going more
into an unscalable marketing to is I've
been on this big kick I think we got
tricked by digital media you know if you
look at what first happened with the
internet everything was so scalable
email marketing really scaled it was he
I mean I went from you listen when your
family business does what we did and
then in a couple years it's doing four
times that and the way you're doing it
is by pressing a button after you write
a couple of things and all the orders
come in you don't even know how to
breathe right look the way I used to do
business was on Saturday when the retail
got busy I would stand on the floor for
14 hours and if I sold you an extra case
of wine every person like boom like
that's how I like 30% up
now there's sudden there's this email
thing and I'm just gathering all this
data and I'm writing like opus one now
available $29.99 press a button
80% open rates nobody else doing it and
like we're doing like eighty thousand
dollars in sales in an hour it was just
like right and then SEO and SEM would
search right
I mean you buy the keywords and you're
just getting customer after customer and
you're not doing anything except being
smart strategically but once you set it
up it does its thing and then landing
page conversion and then banner we talk
everything is quite scalable and then
the Internet
chores and the social media thing comes
along and it's predicated on actually
being human it actually is a throwback
it's actually you have to try you
actually have to read somebody's thing
and be like no Pinot Noir and like if
they look really work and it's throwing
everybody off because all the best email
marketers but for landing page
conversion guys and gals or you know SCM
or all this we're used to being smart
and converting and now you know the
markets changing / there's this other
thing and everybody proposed it because
it doesn't do as well it's not as easy
because it's human and that's awesome
you know what it's awesome to me I think
it's great
I think it's awesome I think you should
work hard I think all great things are
worked you know hard work well I mean
this is sort of like the argument yeah
with with the entitlement culture and
you know sort of everybody wants the
spoon-fed and you know you know I
deserve this business and you're saying
no you have to earn it
you have to jab jab jab and you have to
do the right hook the markets the market
right like like sorry sorry that like
somebody came along price like I'm
buying agency right now I have an agency
with a partner where we represent 20 of
the 30 top vine celebrities right and my
partner comes into my office today goes
others these guys that are undercutting
prices we should be getting five times
more for these vine videos and I'm like
sorry like you know like okay like you
know the markets the market like if
they're offering it and the clients
think it's worth it and it's you know
equal of value then we can't be 5 times
so I mean the markets the market like I
hate when people cry about things like
that right like like sorry that
innovations coming in listen innovation
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you me or
anybody in this room if you do not ride
it it will crush your face and that's it
like like I wish my emails would get
open at 80% and 61% click through I wish
because what everybody else figured out
that email marketing work and now
there's nine billion liquor stores that
do it and it's not as interesting like
it's just you have to evolve okay
like I know that a lot of people want to
get some really just like juicy
techniques and so let's let's talk about
the storytelling okay having the content
respecting the context right so this is
sort of your whole book is about this
you had said that you sold your wine at
cost
I did but you sold your store story at a
premium yes and this is how we should
approach marketing all of us right
I mean sell our stories I mean you
should do whatever you want here's
something I believe in if something is a
commodity and everybody has it it
becomes a price game right so like every
wine that I knew that everybody else had
I just sold it at cost dead cost in boys
cost
I don't mean like how much my labor cost
on top of it I'm talking
I paid $7.99 on the invoice for it you
pay $7.99 because Jersey was a place
where he couldn't settle low cost by law
that pretty much gave us the best prices
thus that brought people in and then
when they came in to buy Kendall Jackson
or Santa Margarita or silver oak or
Joseph Phelps insignia I would grab them
and tell them the romantic story of the
dog that ran around this vineyard in
Paso and they'd be like oh that's so
cool and they'd buy a case of that and
that one was predicated on my
storytelling ability and you know
picking good wine and that when I made
money on and to me at some level in all
of your businesses you have to
understand what's the commodity and
what's not and what's not is where you
need to story tell because that's your
biggest up okay so let's let's get let's
get it right into an example here so I
am a startup okay selling you know
looper for for home cleaning services I
wanna do I wanna start doing the jabs
right so start creating the micro
content but you always say micro content
I set up a wordpress blog right start
creating topics or writing topics like
becoming a media company as you said
right sort of be coming medias coming so
let's let's let's step through this like
make work make a wordpress blog well
let's think we did let's take a big step
back yeah right if you're clean if you
first you have to know who you're
reaching right first you have to really
think about who you're trying to get to
so you have to start demoing out your
business okay so you know if it's twenty
five year old
yeah you have to start really
understanding who you're trying to reach
to me if your startup if you've gotten
any funding
you start by to me the first place to go
is to buy Facebook ads and to buy the
actual customer this is where people are
confused about the value of the Facebook
I think it's marked - by your target
audience to follow you because not to
offer anything not to offer $20 for free
because then you get I mean that but let
me explain why because at least on
Facebook here it's great things
brilliant but in a Facebook world you're
gonna get the lowest common denominator
fan that's gonna follow you just for the
offer right so what you want to do is
just get people that want to follow you
just for what you have right and then
once you get them in you start marketing
to them I mean doing content marketing
on WordPress is great but you're running
a marathon right and so for startups
it's scary because you start getting
dividends a year or two in you might not
be in business so I think there's a lot
of things I would do the first thing I
would do is go to every single apartment
rental kind of anything that could segue
for young professionals blogging network
and offer to blog you know now I know
Matt came out and said no more guest
blogging and what-have-you but yeah you
know I would guess blog I would you've
got to get yourself out in the community
I mean the other thing is Twitter search
I think the quickest way to traction is
Twitter search I would literally search
people that say like my like people
literally tweet my apartments a mess
it's probably good person to like talk
to well in that case like you like
surfer hashtag no it's a search for the
real work real words yeah the real world
I mean to me that's a great way to go
one-on-one look it's you know to me
there's a lot of ways to go about it but
you've got to find your unique place but
I would say here's a good one I would
tell you the incredibly interesting
place would be Pinterest and make
infographics about like the cleaning
part of it and things of that nature
it's your storytelling you thought of
each consumers what I want the format
you know WordPress you know talk about a
topic that air that your demographics
interested and then tweet right have
sort of like the value proposition
pointing back to your blog yeah but
before you yeah if you're tweeting - no
but doesn't get [ __ ] right see that's
actually
okay so look again listen here's what's
great about social if you don't have a
lot of money it's incredible their
social is the great equalizer of money
if you reason eleven million dollars
convert right and by the way these two
books it's a mix but to get a community
you've got to first go to Twitter search
I mean if you start your your debt Sox
Twitter community has nineteen people
following because it's a frozen Bering
you can't like - it's not gonna do
anything I mean when I my Twitter
profile I literally spent nine hours a
day on some ice it's how I got my
followers you know you know I've got by
answering people's questions about what
red wine is very core they were going to
Napa and slowly but surely those hundred
those two hundred become your base and
they start retweeting by hand back then
and all that so I think the first thing
you have to do is grab your first 500
person audience and the only way to do
that is through sweat and blood and okay
you know winding yes so the content in
context like you said tumblr in the past
and I mean II guess will probably be
good Pinterest high-quality professional
pictures right so a nice house you know
women probably want to like pin it till
they want their apartment to look like
that you know yes Instagram you said
infographics it seems more real life
pictures infographics for Pinterest so
veterinarian sorry and then Facebook yes
facebook facebook you can really do
anything you go on to issue this I mean
obviously anybody gifts don't work on
that platform if you're Facebook you can
do a whole lot of things I mean listen I
don't know how many of you guys are
using Facebook dark posts right now but
if any of you will have AB dollars to
spend Facebook dark posts how many
people are familiar with that term great
so they're great this makes me pumped so
Facebook right now has a product called
dark posts I think the official term is
unpublished post you can literally
target anybody on Facebook you can
literally right now even if they're fans
of your page will not target people that
are 21 to 24 they're fans of this that
[ __ ] eat cheeseburgers on Wednesday I
mean the data goes deep right and I
would tell you right now that's probably
so for example you know if you think
about is that we're talking about
cleaning apartment siding catches over
there
the apartments right yeah so like to me
that's really interesting because you
could really target people that live in
New York City that literally graduated
from college in May looking it's so
granular to people that you would think
need to get to her apartment clean you
can you can go older if you want and the
messaging is different right look if
you're gonna put a picture about your
cleaning service to 31 to 40 year old
Upper East Side of mom's you're gonna
have a different story to tell them than
22 to 24 year old dudes in Brooklyn you
know different and you can target even
if they're fans or not fans of your site
that has been the biggest conversion
funnel Facebook dark posts with the
proper content contextual to who you're
targeting has been the biggest
conversion funnel ads for me since
Google AdWords 2000 - well I mean Seth
Godin gave me a great quote for my book
write a nice blog post I immediately had
my designer create a little picture with
Seth beautiful mall tan with a little
quote from it and with you know that's
the picture and the link was and here's
Gary's book on Amazon with a link and I
ran that picture against people that
were fans of Seth Godin on Facebook it
dismantled it killed and the conversion
was the Buddha press like in two minutes
my book one before I came out look from
a thousand on a bizarre-looking 98 right
so that's gonna work anyway so so what
sort of tools can we use you know
there's a lot of sites here what sort of
tools can we use right now so I'll write
else I'll son maybe across brand watch
HootSuite googling stuff or local
response Salesforce market marketing
Club you know here's what I think about
tools right I really don't know how to
use a power drill right does it work
yes but you know the ROI of a piano to
me is zero because I don't know
the ROI of a piano to Billy Joel has
been over a billion dollars so tools are
great but everybody wants to sit around
be like oh we're gonna get a huge suite
or buddy media or wildfire right and
it's gonna be awesome I mean Google
Analytics if you spend your whole life
on it from an e-commerce standpoint is
like the most unbelievable thing you've
ever seen Google Analytics not because
we're honest billing is absurd it
[ __ ] works but you have to spend 10
hours a day going through all that data
testing doing all the variable things
that you have to and people are lazy and
they don't so so to me all these tools
are fine but if you don't use them
properly and look very honestly most of
these platforms Facebook Twitter what
have you use them natively they're just
fine HootSuite lets you blast that to
all the networks the same stuff
completely against what I believe in
because you're not making content that's
contextual to the platform so you know
could you talk about the in the book
yeah something that you wanted to write
but you didn't know what kind of point
did you want to that you wish you you
wrote in the book that I don't know what
interview you're digging from I really
don't remember
okay pologize okay I mean like here are
some of the things I didn't write about
like that I you know I wish the book
timing was a little bit different for
example LinkedIn has massively changed
as a platform since I finished the book
right you know and has become
dramatically more valuable where they're
going with company pages it's really
interesting to me and if you understand
a psychology of a CFO when they're on
LinkedIn and you had a story tell it to
them even if you're selling wine or so
LinkedIn would have been interesting for
me to go a little bit further on yeah
you know there's there's a lot of you
know it's tough to write a book about
current events because everything's
shifting so quickly right Facebook
organic reach is dipped since the book
has come out I mean there's a lot going
on okay well let me ask you a better
question what was your favorite case
study in the
my favorite case study in the book was
probably the Lil Wayne Facebook post
where I said congratulations Weezy
you're the first person after Facebook
into my space because he was just
spamming the living [ __ ] out of his
community the reason is my favorite is I
remember when I was writing it I was
like oh man I hope Birdman doesn't kill
me okay so let's go fast forward here
like your angel investing because I'm
sure there's a lot of people very
interested in that I mean you've got
some really amazing dill flow when you
got started you you you weren't one of
the best and Twitter and Facebook is
that correct 2008 and Twitter I bought
the original CFO's stopped blinking left
the company
okay so that was 2007 ago which was good
Facebook was 2009 I made a video in 2008
on garyvaynerchuk.com that said Facebook
should be worried about this thing
called Twitter it went viral and
Facebook they invited me to fly out I've
spoken for the whole company sucks liked
what I said we became friendly and I'm
in 2009 I bought my Facebook stock from
marks parents so that was good tumblr
right really good well so so this is so
I wanna just kind of read off some of
your investments but start starting for
2009 simp simply geo which got bought up
by urban there's airship a key wire I
lost money we did okay go Walla in karma
with things while I was an occupier I
broke even okay
karma was great because that was
Facebook you guys never karma but give
that that was not my facebook that was
very good right right and then and then
wildfire which probably Wofford was a
big win that was bought by Google Google
inch cash right no milk milk too was
milk the same way cuz no cup oh yeah
made a little bit of money okay all
right
supportive with LinkedIn and Birchbox
and path so my question would be to you
is what sort of like what is your
favorite invest you know investment
themes you know going forward
entrepreneurs I bet on the jockey
course every time so if you're gonna
write a $50,000 check today who would
that setup look like I don't give a [ __ ]
it's just how do I feel about the
hustler got it so you have to meet thee
you have to meet the FOB you got to
shake his hand see the fire in his belly
or her hand her favorite investment bar
none is Birchbox they got a bunch of
nose i sat in a coffee shop
Starbucks somewhere in town i sat down
with Katya
Hayley and for seconds I was like I'm in
and they got all emotional excited and
they're like we got so many knows in a
row Gary you don't know how much this
means
and I walked home that day was a summer
day it was like 40 blocks from homes
like we get some exercise in and someone
around 20 blocks in I was like why the
[ __ ] did they get so many knows this is
so obvious and it was the first time I
was ever like on this female
entrepreneur it was like you know I
wonder if it was two ugly dudes if they
would have got yeses right and I was
just interesting you know cuz my mom is
my hero my daughter is my life you know
so you know I'm I'm a wildfire as
Victoria ransom I've done it I'm
probably to my I mean my female
entrepreneurial that investments are at
the top of my ROI so forgets to talk
about predictions cuz you had predicted
that Facebook was gonna buy Instagram so
let's let's talk about more predictions
we would yeah who do you think this
Pinterest gonna be bought out um no I
think that ship sail I think Pinterest I
always thought that Google would
consider Pinterest Pinterest is very
Google yeah you know its intent to buy
if you think about what makes Google
AdWords a great business is search not
always but has a lot of an attempt to by
Pinterest is intent to buy when I look
at the data of like what females pin
it's either what they want to buy or
what they wish they could buy you know
there's other things but there's a lot
of it in there I think it should be very
very very big
everything's about things to be way
bigger than everybody in this room dicks
so really go happy oh I think I could
but I think if the economy stays well I
don't I don't [ __ ] with Wall Street yeah
but if the economy stays well not to me
feels like an IPO company cuz it's
already raised it's such a I mean where
are we now three billion like that thing
these things are getting so big so I
don't know I think I think I think Ober
is gonna go I think that's close to IP
like I think in a you know - that's
gonna be a huge one that's a real cash
business um what about force where i
think dennis and team have to really
figure out how to make it a business and
so but I think that well I'm a big fan
of Dennis I hope so I was never a
Foursquare user even though I believed
in the check in concept I think I think
check-ins a passive game I don't think
we want to do it I think we're gonna
want our device to do it for us but I
think because I think privacy is
overrated
yeah and so will be interesting to see
what happens with those guys I think
that when I'm you know I'm not great at
predicting here's why I predicted
Instagram yeah I just know that pictures
are the killer app right and I think
that I just assumed that Facebook knew
that as well and and I'm just a fan of I
think marks they grossly underestimated
CEO I think it'll play out to be one of
the great CEOs I think he really gets it
it's hoping give us some good
predictions but make this one easy what
do you who said it who's gonna be the
the winner of the Super Bowl no so tell
me about this Impala wrong one of two
teams here's what I can definitely say
I'm so [ __ ] happy it's not the
Patriots you can I hope the Broncos win
because one of my best friend's is a
Broncos fan but I think see I mean I'll
go with Seattle okay
and who do you think I mean have you
been following some of those the social
media like marketing for the Super Bowl
ads so who do you think would be a
winner you know I think after last
year's Oreo tweet it's like change I
mean that was that shape when that
happened before it started getting hired
I literally emailed my entire company
and said our business is about to change
and it did I mean it's what we do for a
living we do real-time content I think
everybody's gonna be waiting I mean I
think you see a lot of bad [ __ ] every
brand try to do something about what
just happened on the play before I went
to commercial
everybody's gonna be reaching and trying
to replicate it I don't think it's about
that I mean I'm sure plain brands will
do well sure 80 of my brands or my teams
are sitting in the office right now
strategizing but I think we'll see some
average work at best I'm not you know I
don't know I mean I think I think that's
the one place Super Bowl is the one time
I think it's worth running a TV
commercial so I'm a little bit more
curious what happens there because
people are actually paying attention to
the commercials as sport right yeah yeah
absolutely so we're gonna open up to Q&A
and so before I open this up
what so this is sort of like the last
question though there's going to be
another last question up the Q&A but if
you were 15 years ago sitting in front
of in front of a badass thought leader
one third what sort of advice would you
want to hear hear from that from that
guy
nothing nothing honestly my biggest flaw
is I'm just completely all and consumed
in my own brains I I've rather if after
I write two more books I'm gonna be
write as many books as I've read my
biggest strengths and miss my biggest
strengths and weakness is my lack of
education I have too much ego like I
don't want advice from anybody I have
zero Mentors
I'm just in my own brain I'd much rather
much rather look at the front screen of
every one of your iPhones or Android
devices I'd rather see the front screen
of everybody's phone in here and get
advice from anybody I don't give a [ __ ]
about advice I want to see behavior okay
and and you have sort of
a ten book deal with with HarperCollins
right that's what was referred in when I
wrote it okay what I mean it wasn't
gonna go down that's true but what the
contract said was if crush it hit a
certain threshold I was able to hop out
which it did okay so if you ever look if
you if any of you were so awesome and
you have all three of them you'll see
the first one that says Harper studios
but the last two have been Harper
business okay so I don't I do have to
write one more jab - jab right hook I
signed a two book deal yeah so I do have
to write one more I've been actually
thinking about writing a book called
crushed it I have like I have I have
literally like 5,000 emails that I've
saved of people that read the book and
have an awesome things happen to them so
I feel kind of lazy and I'm like [ __ ]
I can view these 5,000 people bang it
out I'm really gonna do that I think
okay for Q&A so alright thanks he said
that yes path path is the only place my
wife lets me post pictures of our
children so like I think privacy's
r-rated but my wife doesn't and thus she
doesn't one our children everywhere then
they're not going to be right and so
here's what I mean by so I clarified
privacy is overrated
we and our actions prove that we don't
care that much about privacy
we just do it every day it's what we do
and the reason we don't is actually
something that I find massively
fascinating I believe the reason that we
don't care that much about privacy is
because of three things number one it's
about what happens right things we
really care about is the health and
well-being of our friends and family and
ourselves and our money right how many
people here have been hit by credit card
fraud raise your hand out reason hi okay
about 30 percent of the room right if
when you were hit by credit card fraud
you didn't get your money back we'd
really give a [ __ ] about privacy right
but since you do get it back yeah you
maybe inconvenience but all the
convenience that comes we care about our
time and our convenience more than our
privacy
because the truth is when myspace came
out everybody's like don't let your kids
on myspace cuz they're gonna get raped
at the mall right like I don't know you
guys remember that and I was like
literally the conversation meanwhile
since over the last 10 years if you look
at the data we've got much safer because
every one of us is a media company we
all phones on us it's harder to kidnap
somebody in the middle of the day right
because everybody can take out their
phone and take a picture and make a
video I mean that's just the truth you
know and so what what's interesting to
me is that I think people are the most
underrated brand in the world I think
the human being is the number one
underrated brand here's why mainstream
media for the last 80 years on the moons
has a reported and story told to us
about the bottom point zero zero zero
zero one percent of our society the
people that kill and do all these wrong
things meanwhile when you look think
about the damage that we can all do to
each other right now is scary but we
just don't do it and that's why I think
inherently we know that and I think that
that's why our actions are all value my
time over my privacy because I really
can't get hurt and of course it happens
but you know you start where you start
based on what you're trying to
accomplish so like I would ask you what
you're trying to accomplish because if
you're starting and you sell a new
sneaker that you've invented to 12 to 18
year olds you start on a vine snapchat
and Instagram like but if you're
starting and you're selling to 42 year
old females you go on Pinterest and
Facebook you start with who you want to
get to is and that's you reverse
engineering got it
oh yeah I mean email open rates have
collapsed over the last 36 months I mean
Facebook Facebook's
got its own headaches I mean listen I
think Facebook dropping reach on
everybody is the best thing Facebook
could do it's why we still like it to
some degree I know that 22 and under
doesn't I get that but here's how I
think about Facebook you know how when
you were a lot of you are still in a
young demo but like when you're 18 to 28
32 whatever you want to call it and
you're younger two years maybe before
you're married your number one job is to
go to like all the new restaurants and
the new clubs you're an adventurer you
go to all these different things when
you get older especially when you get
married you start going to your favorite
places right you go look at a 40 year
olds habits now they've got their four
restaurants right and so that's what I
think Facebook is I'm trying to figure
out what the ages but there's some age
and I'm gonna call it somewhere between
28 and 33 that those people are not
going anywhere
because I mean you're 42 year old aunt
is not leaving Facebook anytime soon
right because everything's been mapped
and so I think it's close but what
Facebook has a huge advantage of is
targeting right like and if they just
figure out I mean I think the most
brilliant I mean listen I think the most
brilliant thing Facebook is doing is
having EdgeRank
I think Twitter needs it Twitter is a
huge firehose I mean if you look at the
data on what Twitter is doing and what
Facebook's doing Twitter's noisier right
because we don't cut the people we
follow it's a habit that we don't do so
Facebook's doing it for us we could all
benefit from Twitter looking at the data
and unfollowing for us the people that
we haven't favored it retweeted or reply
to in the last year you would all like
Twitter better and so I'm not sure you
know to really answer you it will I mean
the last line of this book is everything
I just talked about will be ruined by
marketers it's what we do so Facebook's
been ruined by Marcos Instagram is gonna
be ruined by market I mean jelly comes
out in two minutes
and I put GE on jelly in one second my
client and our
Jet Li's ruined you think you're getting
ruined in 20 minutes now right I mean so
I think that um I think it's still much
more viable than people think I'm
actually pumped that everybody's right I
mean every articles now like the kids
don't like Facebook right meanwhile I go
to all these brands and they're like we
don't like Facebook we need the people
that buy it's like there's just cynicism
for both sides right there like one side
they're talking about the kids aren't on
it on the other side you know the habits
that I see between 35 and 55 year olds
on Facebook is extraordinary the buying
habits are extraordinary I don't know
when it depletes it will but do I think
Facebook disappears I don't
not to mention Facebook owns Instagram
which is the new Facebook I'm eeen can
you be more specific I mean I think the
advice you know listen here's what I
know the truth is undefeated right like
if you're asking from a business
standpoint if you build a good business
people are gonna care if you're an alien
right so you know I think all these
issues minorities you know women in tech
minorities in tech is something I have a
lot of heart for especially like when I
go and speak I do a lot of pro bono in
certain places of that nature they're
pissed that's the white man angry at
this answer
I think I just want to finish this I I
think you know for me I'm completely
color and gender blind when it comes to
business I don't
I just love capitalism so much I think
you know everything's hard you know
everybody has challenges
I'm very heightened aware the women in
my life my mom sister daughter and you
know life I mean that is my crew
I love AJ and my dad but like I'm very
heightened to that conversation um four
of my five best friends that were who's
been at my wedding are minorities I'm
heightened I was an immigrant that
didn't speak English
I'm heightened to a lot of these things
but the truth is you're also talking to
somebody who loves to climb right I hate
winning by the way I hate it I almost
think that I left why and I gave you an
answer to my left wine I'm not so sure
that I'm being so cute
I left wine when I felt like I was the
guy in one not only had the biggest
store but had the biggest presence I
loved the climb I actually think that
you know I like the the underdog status
you know and so I think whether you're a
white dude or a minority female the
actual answer this question is to
execute you got executed nobody's gonna
care if you can actually make it happen
period
you know what's funny about Bitcoin I
really wish I had thoughts on Bitcoin
let me explain
I'm just not mathematically smart I
can't even figure out really people if
you know it's a real currency I'm like
no I don't I have no [ __ ] idea what
you're talking about I do not know what
central bank is I have no [ __ ] clue
so I want to desperately have thoughts
on Bitcoin I'm just not smart enough
it's really - I want it back I just
don't get it
it sounds great right like neutral like
yeah I didn't it sounds right like I
mean but it's so weird right like
[ __ ] I'm like I like God one of my
guys like I need to set up a server to
mine for Bitcoin he's like if you can
tell me anything of what you just said
in practicality we'll do it I'm like I
can't do it you know I can't you know
five minutes to sit down with me okay
if you can beat me in
rock-paper-scissors right now
I do like I do like music but I don't
have five minutes I'm pissed right now
so uh Gary I have one phone okay if you
could add one key player to your Jets
and the NFL who would that be
oh we desperately need a wide receiver
who would like ooh um well Megatron
you know like if I could just pick okay
Calvin Johnson you know I mean being
realistic knowing who the free agents
are sir I would take maybe Sanders for
the Steelers gonna be free agent
maybe Decker I don't want you I don't
want Adam in that [ __ ]
Nick scares me seems like he's weirdly
finished at 26
and so do you have sort of a timeline of
when you're gonna be buying yeah you
know I don't think of it that langa you
know I think I think I'm gonna do it I
really do okay and I know that it's like
laughable I get it but like it's gonna
make for such a great story like when I
do it I'm like I'm so proud you're gonna
do it no I can tell you're gonna do it
you know I'd like to be 63rd 22 years
I'm 38 I'd love to get it at sixth you
know I don't want to be [ __ ] 90 right
like I don't know I'd like to be 60
you know Woody Johnson is at an age
where he's you know not gonna sell it
hopefully he stays nice I would he stay
nice and healthy for many reasons being
a good human and and the fact that I'd
like him to own it for another you know
my big fear is that he sells it anywhere
in the next decade because that's gonna
then put me in a tough spot
so I have a better value proposition for
you okay
I heard you post this on Facebook then
you were actually a bigger Yankees fan
back in the day and the day Tommy
Mattingly right yeah I mean I grew up a
would you like to back to a good point
there once the Yankees started winning
all these I mean finished at 430 guys
baseball is not a sport baseball is a
business the New York Yankees spent four
hundred thirty five million dollars this
offseason you know the Kansas City
Royals are gonna spend that in the next
40 years
baseball's a fucked-up sport I beat it
for that I hate that it's not pure and
but but I like this I mean I want to
love baseball I love fantasy baseball
I'm all about fantasy baseball
I don't play fantasy football like most
normal people because I love the Jets
too much and I could never just like
pick anybody else so I was thinking
about what would be a good gift for you
and I was thinking well hey let's get
him to Jets jersey obviously I looked it
up in somebody got to it just serving
Jersey I've got all those well has
anyone given you given you a